[Musique]
bonjour à tous émission spéciale du 7-8
échos et nous sommes avec patrice
carmouze bonjour nicolas borne est bien
installé dans on est très bien installés
alors c'est le gris foncé cimbron faut
absolument véhicules utilisés par
l'armée terre nous allons parler
aujourd'hui du battle la terre c'est une
structure dédiée à l'innovation pour
l'armée de terre absolument et moi je
vais vous faire découvrir deux
technologies toute nouvelle d'abord une
qui s'appelle le provoque
pour d'autres c'est une nuit on appelle
ça une mule c'est à dire c'est un engin
vers lequel on transporte du matériel et
qui et téléopérés dire et il est
pratiquement autonome comme un soft qui
est quelqu'un qui ne télé au père mère
et puis autre innovation c'est le mc 2
ctoc pourvoi de véhicules pratiquement
autonome ou qui suivent en tout cas un
véhicule de tête et vous allez voir
c'est assez extraordinaire
eh bien on y va tv 78 au battle la terre
c'est parti
[Musique]
et pour commencer cette émission nous
sommes avec le colonel sébastien bonjour
mon colonel bon journée colore vous
dirigez le battle l'aptr vous pilotez en
fait l'activité d'une quinzaine de
personnes ici sur le plateau de satory
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
les missions du battle d'ap terre les
missions du battle d'acteurs sont sur
trois volets le premier volet c'est de
capter les solutions innovantes qui
peuvent faciliter la vie des soldats sur
le champ de bataille dans un univers
très proche
la deuxième mission qui est la suite
directe de cette captation c'est de
tester tout ce que nous envisageons
comme solution innovante et la troisième
mission est de recommander à l'état
major de l'armée de terre dont je
dépends
les solutions les plus pertinentes pour
améliorer la vie opérationnelle des
combattants alors on le précise tout de
suite à des véhicules autour de nous
sont pas forcément issus du battle la
terre ici nous avons un griffon ça
existait avant le battle l'aptr par
contre la mule ça ça a un intérêt par
rapport aux battles la terre alors la
mise en place de ces deux équipements me
permet de bien expliquer ce que savait
faire l'armée de terre et le ministère
des armées jusqu'à présent est-ce
qu'elle s'est toujours très bien faire
c'est développer des programmes
d'armement majeurs mettre au point un
blindé griffon de ce type là c'est une
dizaine d'années de travail intégré avec
des études de très haut niveau
beaucoup d'intégration technologique
mais quand on développe une solution du
début jusqu'à sa mise en service
en une dizaine d'années la mise à jour
aux derniers standards technologiques
prend toujours un petit peu de décalage
c'est la raison pour laquelle il a été
envisagé de créer un laboratoire qui a
détecté des solutions qui pourraient
rentrer sur le champ de bataille
beaucoup plus rapidement donc c'est sûr
des objets beaucoup plus légers comme
par exemple cette mule ce robot qui va
accompagner le combattant sur le champ
de bataille alors la structure a été
créée en 2019 comment se passent les
relations en fait avec les militaires
ceux qui sont en opex sur le terrain le
militaire qui est en opération qui est
sur le terrain c'est l'origine de tous
nos sujets d'inspiration pour le
développement de projets d'innovation
il nous fait remonter quelque chose qui
lui manque quelque chose qu'ils veulent
in est quelque chose qu'on pourrait
améliorer ça arrive aux battles l'aptr
par un circuit de transmission d'idées
qui fonctionnent très correctement et
qui nous permet de dire ça c'est
réalisable
on va chercher un partenaire industriel
par exemple pour donner vie à cette idée
et il a testé sur le sur le terrain
alors mon colonel de battles la terre ce
n'est pas uniquement l'armée terre on va
le voir dans quelques instants il ya
d'autres acteurs mais d'abord je vous
propose d'écouter la ministre des armées
florence parly que nous avions rencontré
en janvier dernier à rambouillet
ça n'est pas par hasard que c'est à
satory satory c'est à la fois un lieu
emblématique de l'armée terre où il y à
des ateliers très important de
réparation et de maintien en condition
opérationnelle des matériels terrestres
mais c'est aussi un lieu sur lequel se
trouve implanté de très grandes
universités paris saclay de très grandes
écoles mais aussi un secteur automobile
très important avec nos grands
constructeurs
bref c'est un lieu c'est un écosystème
extrêmement favorable pour générer cette
innovation alors viens d'entendre la
ministre tandis que finalement le
plateau de satory c'est pas un hasard
c'est un écosystème qui est favorable en
fait à l'innovation dans le secteur de
la défense
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
justement avec quels acteurs de
travailler pourquoi c'est si favorable
ce territoire alors vous l'avez dit ce
n'est pas du tout par hasard que le
balte ldap terre a été implanté sur ce
terrain de satory qui est tout près des
états majors mais aussi de tout ce qui
compte en termes d'industrie de défense
en termes de recherche en termes de
monde académique
en gros tous les talents qui peuvent
nous permettre de rendre de réaliser de
manière très concrète
toutes les idées d'innovation qui passe
dans le plan de charge du battle l'aptr
ce plateau de satory il nous permet dans
un premier temps physiquement d'avoir
accès à des pistes d'essai à un terrain
de décès qui est absolument remarquable
mais à quelques centaines de mètres
seulement du battle l'aptr nous sommes
déjà en contact direct avec les
industriels conventionnelle du monde de
la défense comme par exemple nexter ou
arcus et
des instituts de recherche comme par
exemple l'institut bd comme qui lui va
permettre de faire le lien entre nos
besoins militaires
il va interpréter les cases usages que
nous donnons qui sont la clé de beaucoup
de développement d'idées d'innovation et
nous mettre en relation avec le monde et
le monde industriel pour trouver des
solutions intégrées vd comme c'est un
des acteurs qui nous permet d'établir
des partenariats où tout le monde est
gagnant et c'est nouveau finalement de
cette méthode de travail pour l'armée
terre l'open innovation l'open
innovation une expression un peu à la
mode dans le monde de l'industrie privée
a une chance un petit peu particulier
dans le monde des armes et l'open
innovation à l'origine qu'est ce que
c'est l'innovation ouverte c'est une
idée d'innovation qui vient de la base
qui peut venir de soldats qui peut venir
de deux chercheurs et caetera et qui est
déployé au sein de la structure
la façon dont on traduit l'open
innovation c'est aussi l'utilisateur au
centre de toute la recherche de
solutions et c'est ça qui prime dans le
travail du battle l'aptr c'est que rien
ne se décide pour le bien du soldat sans
la vie du soldat tout ce que fait le
battle l'aptr c'est de prendre des
prototypes des solutions innovantes pas
encore testé les tester sur le terrain
avec des utilisateurs pour en tirer des
conclusions sur leur intérêt
opérationnel
autres pistes de développement le fait
d'intégrer le battle l'aptr dans tous
les travaux du pôle d'innovation qui
vient de se lancer autour du plateau de
satory qu'on appelle gaïa j'ai haï 4 à
ce qui veut dire le groupement academy
industrie ingénieurs d'ile-de-france
pour l'innovation au profit de l'armée
de terre c'est un long un long non pour
beaucoup de beaucoup d'ambition gaia qui
a par exemple vocation à donner suite au
projet mc2 qui est ce projet deux
convois de véhicules autonomes qui a
déjà pris une première réalité et qui
pourra devenir beaucoup beaucoup plus
ambitieux grâce aux synergies qui sont
créés autour du plateau de satory
et justement mon colonel le projet mme
ces deux va être découvert par patrice
carmouze en deuxième partie d'émission
mais d'abord patrice carmouze va
découvrir le provoque
l'outil que vous voyez derrière moi
c'est un engin qui est utilisé par
l'armée française au mali et c'est une
découverte avec l'un des hommes
[Musique]
chef de bataillon renier bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le chef de projet de ce cet
engin qu'on appelle le pro bottes et ça
tout à fait oui
projet qui a commencé il ya 18 mois
avec
à
un contrat qui a été passé un appel à
concurrence
une société a été désigné et remplir en
plus a été est sortie gagnante de ce
compte de ce marché là dessus et nous
avons acquis pas très loin d'ici
c'est une société qui est dans l'essonne
qui sait la société gaci qui est à une
vingtaine de kilomètres d'ici qui met et
qui construit c'est ces robots c'est
probable
nous en avons eu 1 en juillet l'année
dernière et quatre hommes nous ont été
livrées fin janvier de cette année
racontez nous ce qu'est cette
technologie de lepreau vote
et puis à quoi ça servait d'abord un peu
comment ça marche et téléopérés ça donc
c'est un robot qui est télé opéré il ya
un opérateur qui a une télécommande
on a deux modèles de télécommande une
télécommande qui permet de thé opéré le
à vue le robot est une autre
télécommande qui permet de télé opéré le
robot hors des vues 1 jusqu'à à peu près
800 m donc le gros intérêt de ce robot
sait que c'est un robot mur qui a une
capacité de déplacement du muc là ça
veut dire quoi
mules qui est en fait qui est une charge
de transformer pour transporter là pour
transporter qu'à une capacité de
transport de 750 kg qui une vitesse de
déplacement de huit kilomètres heure 1
et qui permet à un groupe de combat de
s'alléger au niveau de son matériel
voilà au lieu que ce soit les militaires
qui porte les charges on va les mettre
dans le provoque et le problème passe
exactement où passent les militaires
c'est le but
voilà donc de pouvoir suivre les soldats
qui sont à pied un et de prendre et de
reprendre exactement le même itinéraire
pour pouvoir transporter leur matériel
et les amener au plus près
de la zone de contact ou là ils pourront
se récupérer leur matériel et mener leur
action de combat
alors on disait c'est téléopéré donc la
formation de militaires qui télé aux
perses se provoque
c'est quoi c'est combien de ces c'est
l'équivalent de quatre jours ouvrés pour
acquérir les compétences en télé
opération est en maintenance sur le
matériel avec les différentes opérations
comme mettre en place les chenilles qui
sont là on peut mettre des se dire
absolument tout terrain assez
complètement tout terrain là les
chenilles sont pas montées on aimait
par-dessus les roues et ce qui lui donne
une autre capacité de déplacement entre
autres dans des terrains qui sont
beaucoup plus
compliqué et gras voilà et donc le
militaire acquiert cette formation en
peu près quatre jours et après il est
capable de manoeuvrer et d'utiliser ce
matériel sur un théâtre d'opérations on
le verra d'ailleurs mais ça passe
absolument par tous actuellement il ya
je crois des prototypes de se provoquent
qui sont au mali
c'est exact quatre engins ont été
déployés au mali début mars pour une
durée de
de quatre mois sur le théâtre malien en
exploration avec une unité d'infanterie
qui les a intégrés dans son dispositif
alors ça c'est très intéressant parce
que vous allez avoir sur deux retours
d'expérience c'est à dire que les
militaires qui sont sur le terrain vous
vous dire ben voila si on avait ça en
plus où c'est osé ça et ça vous
permettre de modifier c'est ses propos
c'est le but recherché est surtout
d'avoir un retour d'un retour de
l'opérationnel sur l'emploi de ce
matériel là et aussi l'emploi futur des
robots et de la robotique au sein de
l'armée de terre parce que ça ne se
limitera pas uniquement aux unités
d'infanterie
mais ce type de matériel que décliner
dans toutes au près de toutes les unités
1 que ça soit du soutien ou de l'appui
jusqu'à l'unité de mêlée c'est une sorte
de révolution quand même un pour les
pour les médecins militaires sur le
terrain c'est une grosse révolution oui
puisque on rentre dans une nouvelle ère
l'ère de la robotique
on a déjà fait un
des grands chamboulements entre autres
avec qui ce qui est des drones qu'on a
intégré dans nos unités et les robots
terrestres sont dans cette continuité
ce que je vous propose c'est peut-être
de d'aller voir comment ça commence à
fonctionner avec plaisir on va le
déplacer on va le faire dépasser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on poursuit ce 7,8 échos spécial battle
l'aptr la structure dédiée à
l'innovation pour l'armée de terre avec
les industriels partenaires de ce
programme nous sommes au mobile app de
bd comme est avec nous philippe bas taux
directeur général dvd comme bonjour
bienvenue
philippe gosset vous êtes le chef de
projets robotiques pour le groupe nexter
bonjour bonjour et christian jacq
bonjour directeur innovation pour arcus
on va commencer avec vous philippe
bateau vous dirigez un institut de
recherche spécialisé dans les mobilités
futur vous travaillé notamment sur le
véhicule autonome
en quoi ce travail sur le véhicule
autonome peut intéresser le battle la
terre on voit bien que le sujet de la
mobilité autonomie concerne bien sûr les
particuliers qui ont envie de passer un
peu plus de temps libre dans leur
automobile médias aussi des applications
très concrètes très opérationnelle pour
les forces et est ce qu'on a travaillé
ensemble avec arcus avec nexter et et
nîmes
ce sont des systèmes de convois
autonomes qui sur le théâtre des
opérations peuvent se déplacer avec le
moins d'interventions humaines
on va le voir notamment pour parler du
projet mc2 patrice carmouze l'atc on le
verra juste après on reviendra sur
comment on adapte aussi les technologies
civiles à au secteur industriel de la
défense mais avant le groupe nexter donc
on connaît le groupe pour les véhicules
militaires le système d'armement aussi
c'est tout naturellement que vous avez
rejoint le battle la paire finalement
figues bosser oui tout à fait puisque on
travaille beaucoup sur le domaine de la
robotique et l'autonomisation des
véhicules
développer des systèmes mule pour
alléger le fantassin alléger le soldat
pour les accompagner les aider dans leur
tâche de tous les jours et donc allier à
la fois les problématiques d'autonomie
mais aussi les problématiques des
besoins des opérationnels militaire et
on le verra pas ce que vous travaillez
depuis longtemps finalement sur
l'innovation et c'est tout naturellement
que vous avez rejoint le battle la terre
parce que c'est vraiment cette structure
qui va permettre d'accélérer
l'innovation dans le secteur de la
défense
christian jacq donc vous arcus vous êtes
un peu cousin de nexter vous êtes un peu
sur le même secteur d'activité vous
développer des véhicules militaires
anciennement connu sous le nom de
renault trucks defense comment vous
participez vous au battle l'aptr et bien
sûr le battle l'aptr nous avons
participé -déjà- en réfléchissant
ensemble avec vd comme et nexter sur le
principe de cette coopération
le battle la terre est venu avec eux une
idée un concept et nous avons réfléchi à
comment le mettre en oeuvre le plus
rapidement possible et en montant on va
dire de toutes pièces une coopération
entre des acteurs qui la veille ne
s'était pas forcément parlé sur ce sujet
là et ensuite chacun est venu avec son
savoir-faire ses briques technologiques
et donc nous nous avons typiquement
développer des briques d'intelligence de
suivi de convois sur un démonstrateur
qui s'appelle robo't lab et nous avons
donc mixer cette brique technologique de
robots slam avec les briques
technologiques de nexter et avec la
coordination de welkom afin de faire un
vrai qu'on voit qu'on aura qu on a pu
démontrer en à peu près six mois au
battle l'aptr en quoi vous êtes
complémentaires tous les 3 alors que
dans le même secteur d'activité mais au
milieu il y avait des comme ces nouveaux
finalement le secteur industriel de la
défense pour vous oui c'est nouveau et
c'est une très bonne nouvelle parce que
nous notre vocation c'est de faire
travailler ensemble différents acteurs
d'une même filière ont fait dans la
partie civile avec renault et psa qui
sont sur le même marché comme vous
par rapport à leur secteur d'activité et
aussi des équipementiers valeo faurecia
plastic omnium etc
nous notre vocation c'est faire
travailler ensemble pour que les briques
technologiques des uns et des autres
puis ce soit être assemblée soit être un
terreau peuple qui est un sujet
extrêmement important quand on parle de
convois autonome à la fois avait des com
apporte des compétences en matière de
technologie on développe de la
technologie sur la mobilité autonome et
on a aussi des compétences au montage de
projets et finalement nous on intervient
en tant que tiers de confiance dans tout
ça sur les systèmes d'autonomie comment
vous les adaptez vous surveille vos
véhicules vos dispositifs que vous
mettez en place au niveau militaire
donc au niveau militaire on retrouve des
contraintes qui sont à la fois commune
au domaine civil
donc c'est aussi tout l'intérêt de
travailler avec l'institut comme bd
comme pour avoir cet apport du domaine
civil il ya tout un domaine de
fonctionnement de cette autonomie qui
dans la partie commune avec le civil et
après on a tout le les contraintes du
militaire à l'est en tout terrain les
dans des environnements difficiles aller
dans des environnements par nuit par
neige par brouillard et ses étangs de ce
domaine de fonctionnement donc c'est là
où on apporte par rapport à ce qu'on
peut trouver dans le civil qui est déjà
très bien fait cette complémentarité
dans l'autonomie pour alléger la tâche
ce toujours des soldats
et vous chers qu est ce qu on vous la
voyez je suppose qu'il faut aussi
sécuriser ses systèmes parce que
forcément qui dit véhicule militaire dit
vulnérabilité au niveau de la connexion
et puis des systèmes autonomes qui
peuvent être brouillés peut-être tout à
fait alors en fait la sécurisation elle
est déjà très présente dans le véhicule
autonome civiles mais pas de la même
manière dans le sens où le véhicule
autonome civile s'est il faut éviter à
tout prix les accidents incluant en
particulier pertes humaines
nous on est dans un système qui est
légèrement différent je dis pas qu'il
faut évidemment avoir des accidents mais
on a en plus le fait qu'on ait au sein
d'un champ de bataille qui peut y avoir
effectivement des agressions que ceux
des agressions physiques réels ou des
agressions par exemple sur les modes de
communication et donc il ya un aspect
cas d' usage comme le com philippe l'a
souligné qui est assez différent en fait
du véhicule autonome civile qui consiste
tout simplement à transporter quelqu'un
d'un point a à un point b déjà pas
facile mais nous on a une problématique
qui consiste à remplir une mission
en imaginant effectivement toutes les
agressions potentiels tous les imprévus
qui peuvent se passer
et donc on a un aspect sceptiques est
très important de ce point de vue là et
donc on a des solutions qui doivent être
quand même différente parce que en
particulier la reprise en main du
système par l'homme est vraiment très
prévenante dans l'est dans les systèmes
militaires
une question à tous les trois sur cette
collaboration finalement donc là ça
commence avec le système autonome
comment on peut imaginer l'avenir et
quels bénéfices vous en tirer chacun de
votre côté
je pense qu'elle a beaucoup de sujets
inquiets premier sujet de l'opt et
autonome il est très intéressante parce
qu'il est très innovant même temps il
irait point des besoins très concrets
des forces
il ya d'autres sujets autour de
l'énergie par exemple aux signes qui
sont la fois comme un l'industrie civile
et à notre industrie de défense
donc là aussi il y aura des synergies à
mettre en place et ce qui est important
c'est qu'on a maintenant entre
guillemets le vecteur l'outil ce qui
cristallise qui est le bateau de la
terre et la cerise sur le gâteau c'est
qu'on est sur le même territoire
pas seulement dans les yvelines mais
plus précisément encore ici sur satory
donc on est à quelques encablures des
uns des autres avec les pistes avec nos
moyens on va même aussi partager des
bâtiments ensemble donc on a aussi eu
d'écho système territorial qui se prête
bien à des développements futurs
une question des indices est peut-être
en supplément de la question que j'ai
posée auparavant
c'est quelque chose de nouveau l'open
innovation dans le secteur de la défense
alors déjà géré content car cus nous on
appartient au groupe volvo qui est un
groupe de véhicules industriels civils
donc on a déjà dans notre adn cette
capacité à aller voir ce qui se fait
dans le civil et à l'adapter pour le
monde de la défense
1 philippe a parlé de l'énergie nous
aujourd'hui nos solutions d'énergie ce
sont principalement les solutions du
groupe volvo
je crois que de toute façon le monde de
la défense depuis quelques décennies a
pris cette habitude là depuis être
forcément la tête de file de toutes les
technologies mais de prendre des
technologies existantes sur le marché et
de voir comment les adapter au monde de
la défense après c'est vrai qu'on était
dans une logique très techno push en
prenant des grandes techno et en
regardant
comment est-ce qu'on peut les dispatcher
sur le champ de bataille et là on rentre
vraiment dans une logique d'innovation
ouverte et à ce titre je pense que le
battle lab a vraiment un rôle à jouer en
nous permettant de faire des boucles
courte d'avoir des retours et
l'utilisateur très rapide et d'éviter de
faire fausse route pendant plusieurs
années
phil goss et je partage totalement le
point de vue de christian on retrouve
ici on a différents acteurs au sein de
nez on a aussi bien le battle lab pour
les aspects effectivement mise en
relation avec les opérationnels et nous
guider dans les haies dans l'innovation
dans le domaine robotique le champ du
possible est énorme
on est encore à des balbutiements sur le
domaine des gros robots donc dans quels
axes allez on ne sait pas très bien nous
industriels on a dans certaines voient
qu'on est en train de voir
mais il ya beaucoup de possibilités à
explorer donc ce qui est intéressant
avec le battlelog c'est qu'ils vont nous
guider nous dire effectivement cet
axe-là nous intéresse il faut travailler
plus tôt dans cette direction là et
alors justement pour illustrer les
propos vous en avez parlé le projet mc2
et ben on retrouve tout de suite patrice
carmouze qui va nous parler du projet
mc2 un convoi autonome de véhicules et
de robots militaires chef de bataillon
rodier on va parler donc de ce projet
mc2 et puis de cette technique follow me
falloir que nous expliquer d'après ce
projet alors le projet mc2 c'est un
projet qui a été initié par le battle
l'aptr auprès de la société situé bd
comme pour créer une synergie auprès des
industriels de défense donc les
différentes sociétés qui s'y sont priés
qui travaillent pour nous et pour
l'armée de terre généralement un pour le
la création en fait deux convois
autonome
le but étant qu'à long terme on puisse
avoir des véhicules qui se déplace à
derrière un véhicule m sans personnel à
bord ou
le strict minimum et sur des très
longues très longues durées
donc là c'était la première brique en
tant que tel à travers la technologie
follow me qui existe poloni ça veut dire
si moi de dire si moi en anglais tout à
fait on voit bien il ya un véhicule mais
un véhicule m et chaque véhicule
derrière possède un système de radar
avec
un gps qui permet de se positionner
derrière le véhicule et garder une
distance de sécurité avec le véhicule
l'idée c'est qu'ils soient dans les
traces même l'idée est le maître l'idée
futur c'est qu'il soit actuellement dans
les traces même du véhicule m
actuellement avec la technologie follow
me on a un léger décalage donc de régler
ce à quoi les véhicules ont tendance à
couper les virages et l'objectif futur
c'est qu' il soit vraiment danser dans
ses traces pour justement ne pas
rencontrer de problèmes plus on va
étendre le convoi de avoir le dernier
véhicule qui ne correspond pas du tout
et qui peut être qu'il peut me crée un
accident alors vous l'avais dit il ya du
gps et des valeurs qui permettent à ses
véhicules se repérer on peut imaginer
dans des dans des affaires de combat qui
est des brouillages de gps on peut
imaginer qu'ils aient des brouillages de
gps c'est un risque en tous les cas
donc le but c'est d'avoir dans un futur
proche de s'affranchir du gps un parent
en développant des technologies qui
permettront aux véhicules
un soin par de l'intelligence
artificielle ou d'autres technologies de
ce type là de vraiment rester dans au
sein de ce convoi ou derrière un
véhicule m parce que on parle de convois
mais demain ça sera peut-être un
véhicule de combat qui aura
des véhicules qui le suivront qui seront
d
des véhicules autonome et a servi aux
véhicules de combat alors qu'elles
sortent de deux véhicules
on imagine dans ce projet mc2 alors dans
ce projet mc2
là on était sûrs du véhicule tactique
type sherpa pvp et puis il y avait les
véhicules des robots
de nîmes et de nexter qui étaient là
dessus donc c'est un meilleur c'est un
mélange de
là ça a été un mélange de véhicules mais
on peut s'imaginer demain que ça sera
des convois de camions pour la
logistique
ça peut être du transport à paraître du
transport de
de matériel et de biens et demain ça
peut être derrière un char de bataille
c'est ça c'est pas de dessert enfin des
robes des robots des robots autonomes
qui seront a servi un char de bataille
ils recevront des ordres a fait par la
suite parce chars de bataille
alors pour l'instant le véhicule mais
traîné devant on pourrait imaginer qu'il
soit une autre place par exemple je sais
pas c'est une hypothèse que je fais mais
par exemple un véhicule des mineurs qui
soit devant sans personne à bord on peut
on peut parfaitement imaginer c'est pas
quelque chose
10 réalisable qu'israël est donc c'est
quelque chose qui pourrait être fait
dans quelques années avec un véhicule m
et à un robot devant lui un autre
véhicule qui va permettre de l'ouvrir la
voix est de détecter les menaces
potentielles
qui sont sur le terrain aussi bien aux
menaces mine que d'autres menaces en
tant que telle la donc vous avez dit le
projet est à ses débuts
est ce qu'il ya un délai que vous êtes
fixés pour alors que ça bien il n'y a
pas on n'a pas fixé de délai on a voulu
surtout créer une synergie avec avec les
industriels pour essayer de développer
une technologie commune puisque le
savoir est ce que les industriels
arrivent avec leurs propres technologies
qui ne sont pas forcément compatibles
sont pas compatibles comme les autres et
on va se retrouver comme avec nos
téléphones portables au début d année
avec autant de charger qu'on avait deux
modèles de téléphones portables ça c'est
impossible et ça d'un point de vue
opérationnel s'est pas réalisable donc
déjà d'essayer de les inciter à
travailler sur une technologie commune
un pur
continuer à poursuivre ensuite sur sept
ce besoin qui est exprimé par par les
armées merci beaucoup de nous avoir
expliqué ce qu'était ce projet mc2 donc
il va probablement voir le jour d'ici
d'ici quelques années les années et puis
nous voir que retrouver évidemment
nicolas landry merci patrice et merci au
chef de bataillon rodier retour au mobil
avec nos trois invités devaient des
communes extérieures cus on va parler de
la relation homme robot et plus
généralement avec les machines aussi
chez nexter et marcus comment vous
travaillez sur cette relation homme
robot quelle philosophie vous adapter
alors si vous l'avez noté c'est très
important c'est à dire qu'on peut
développer la meilleure technologie du
monde
si l'équipe homme-machine n'est pas
bonne
à ce moment là ça ne marchera pas on est
tous d'accord pour dire que la
robotisation du champ de bataille se
fera à une condition c'est que
finalement le robot soit plus efficients
que l'homme dans les tâches qui lui sont
assignées et donc si si si c'est
vraiment compliqué à utiliser et que
c'est plus facile d'envoyer trois hommes
sur le terrain qu'un robot et ben le
robot ne s'imposera pas et donc c'est
très important
j'irai en parallèle de toutes les
briques technologiques d'intelligence de
reconnaissance de terrain et c'est de
développer une vraie un vrai
savoir-faire d'interaction entre l'homme
et la machine de manière à faire en
sorte qu'on soit sûr que lorsque ces
robots arriveront dans les forces
eh ben ils seront simples à utiliser et
ils feront exactement ce que les
opérationnels ont besoin qu'il fasse six
gosses et vous votre relation
effectivement extrêmement importante et
on travaille effectivement sur
l'autonomie pour apporter beaucoup
d'autonomie aux robots qu'ils soient
qu'ils puissent réaliser des tâches de
manière autonome mais c'est toujours
pour au profit d'un opérateur au profit
du soldat et sous la supervision d'un
soldat donc cette relation à mon robot
est essentiel parce que des fois le
robot sera faire des tâches mieux club
et donc le l'homme va se déléguer la
tâche aux robots d'autrefois au
contraire le robot sera moins efficients
et donc aura besoin d'être de
l'opérateur et on essaie de travailler
avec une relation un petit peu comme un
maître chien avec son chien vous
pour que le maître chien et une totale
confiance dans son chien puisse lui
déléguer des tâches lui donner des
ordres de haut niveau que le robot soit
assez autonome pour réaliser ses
déplacements unitaire un peu comme un
chien on va l'envoyer à tel endroit ou
tel endroit et qu'ils puissent revenir
et rendre compte
pays bas taux par rapport à cette
relation qu'est ce que vous pouvez
qu'est ce que peut apporter bd comme par
rapport à cette relation chez les e2
industriels de la défense
moi je pense que le physique vient de
prononcer vraiment le mot clé un qui est
le mot clé de la confiance
dès qu'on ne parle l'interaction homme
machine à le pointer c'est la confiance
c'est vraiment que l'homme ait confiance
dans tous les systèmes automatisés que
des systèmes automatisés puisse se
développer
avec cette dimension confiance pour nous
c'est vraiment les deux les deux faces
d'une même médaille d'une même pièce et
on bosse à la fois sur la partie volet
technologique et sur le volet facteur
humain donc il faut en fait intégré by
design des facteurs humains quand on
développe des systèmes technologiques
qui vont aller j'ai allégé l'humain dans
ces opérations dont vous allez trouver
ici chez bd comme à la fois
effectivement des experts en capteurs en
intelligence artificielle en systèmes de
systèmes et dans les mêmes lieux de
travail
bad est docteur en psychologie en
ergonomie ou en sciences cognitives et
en fait les deux travaillé ensemble sur
le même projet parce qu'effectivement
sinon on va se retrouver dans des
situations on va développer une des
technologies
cette technopole j'entends parler tout à
l'heure et après il ya aucune
utilisation
donc il faut aller assez finement en
fait un bond est facteur humain pour
créer toutes les conditions de
l'adoption de la technologie pour
vraiment des très très finement comment
comment l'homme va apprécier
s'approprier maîtriser cette technologie
parce qu'il doit aussi en devenir sur
l'image effectivement du maître chien il
doit en devenir
il doit en devenir maître une question
peut-être que nos téléspectateurs se
pose qui peut se poser aussi dans
l'opinion publique est ce qu'un jour on
aura des soldats robots des ironman sur
le terrain c'est un peu caricatural
peut-être comme question mais peut-être
que certaines personnes se posent la
question alors des soldats robots
peut-être mais comme l'a dit philippe
tout à l'heure le maître mot c'est la
supervision humaine le mythe du robot
tueur qui décide de lui même ou est-ce
qu'il va tirer ça aujourd'hui c'est
totalement proscrit à la fois par
l'union européenne d'une part et à la
fois dans toutes nos études
d'industriels donc il y aura des robots
sur le champ de bataille ça c'est
évident mais ces robots seront toujours
au service de l'humain et les grandes
décisions à prendre seront prises par un
être humain phil goss et je pense que
c'est le même point de vue elle répondu
la machine est vraiment au service de
l'homme
une machine totalement autonome ne sert
à rien sur le champ de bataille il faut
c'est comme la hiérarchie au sein de
des militaires le soldat tout seul ne
sert à rien il est au sein d'une
organisation il est au profit d'une
organisation complète philippe à toi un
dernier mot avec vous c'est sur ces
études que vous menez au niveau cognitif
alors c'est à la fois la relaxe sur
l'homme homme machine mais c'est aussi
comment l'homme voit la vie cette
relation enfin dans tout cas le
comportement du véhicule autonome par
rapport à l'homme qu'est ce que vous en
ressortez aujourd'hui de vos études par
rapport à ce sujet là bas nous on a de
grands enseignements il ya un premier
enseignement qui va dire sur le plan un
petit peu technique où il est assez aisé
en fait quand vous êtes dans un véhicule
autonome et que le 20 octobre dans une
situation où il peut plus gérer astuces
situé sur lui-même qui va alerter
ce qui doit prendre la commande ça des
techniques commencent à être être assez
bien maîtrisé mais la deuxième dimension
c'est de mesurer le degré de complexité
des situations telles que l'homme va le
percevoir parce que si la machine ne
peut pas traiter la situation s'est calé
face à une situation un petit peu
complexe est ce que nous on cherche à
mesurer au delà du fait je mets deux
secondes pour mettre la main sur le
volant c'est combien de temps jeu mais
pour comprendre la situation en tant
qu'humain que je suis appelé à résoudre
donc en fait on travaille mon sur ce
spectre là et une telle question
ça dépend un peu la complexité des
situations mais aussi par exemple de de
l'activité vous faisiez si vous lisiez
si vous dormez si vous faisiez vous mène
cette activité vous faisiez le temps de
compréhension des situations va pas être
le même
et quand on applique ça au domaine de la
défense voilà le si on est en situation
d'hyper stress ou pas de stress ça c'est
un facteur qui va influencer énormément
les conditions de reprise en main
du système autonome donc c'est toutes
ces choses là qu'il faut qu'il faut
mesurer et que vous allez continuer à me
gérer notamment dans le projet du battle
l'aptr merci à tous les trois philippe
gosset chefs de projets robotiques pour
le groupe nexter philippe mathot
directeur général devait d comme et
christian jacq directeur innovation pour
arcus et c'est ici que s'achève cette
émission le 7-8 échos spécial battle
l'aptr merci de l'avoir suivi je
remercie la section technique de l'armée
de terre et vd comme pour l'accueil et
qui a permis de réaliser ce magazine à
bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]